And to save time I'm just going to copy paste.
aligned
so first we have
we're going to add a carnival kind of evolutional 2D
layer.
This will act.
this
stack that we adding this kind of 2D.
Let me put them on Triple line. So we know what these arguments are.
So this is for the input layer.
Which corresponds to the this dimensions of
the picture with height and color channels?
so input
of the model
we have with height and
number of color channels
This is
the activation function and I guess we haven't talked about
this. We will just have to do it in the next session.
Activation function and I will
show you the tensorflow playground.
If I showed you pictureally you will get the point.
This is the size of the filter.
And this is this number of filters you have.
32 64
I'm graph filters.
So you can take any Carnival 2D layer.
And activate this argument input shape and this will
in fact become the input layer and the first Carnival 2D
layer.
that we will use max pool d
Max pool two dimensions
again, that's the size of the filter.
This is the size.
Excuse me.
This is the size of the
size of the max pulley
Matrix
Number of filters of the same number as kernels. No, we
use filters and curls interchangeably.
So what you're asking here is now is the number of photos
the same number of filters.
Filters and kernels we use interchangeably.
Okay.
And then we have another carnivore to kind of 2D layer.
So I'm gonna copy paste.
Because what we want to do.
If I bring you back to this diagram.
here
imagine what we do is we take our original picture.
and we use a
we convolve it with the filter.
And then we get this outline image.
From this outline image we will get the max pool.
We'll get the strongest activations, but we still want to
further.
identify the important
patterns in this picture
so
This is not exactly the max pool layer. But imagine
it is the max pool layer. All we want to
do is take this.
And further decompose it.
Because you can see in this picture.
It is clear that it is ahead at least to
us, but it can be clear or still.
So we can for example.
We have some.
Shade of green the forehead some Darkness on
the left side of the face some brightness on the
dark side of the face. So we want to call the convolve this again Max
pull it to further to further,
you know, make it clear that this is a
face and even remove the background.
That's the point here.
Now the correct combination of how many Carnival 2D layers you
need how many Max pulley Max pool layer. You
need really depends on
experimentation
you would try this configuration first. Look at
the metrics. Is it good?
Perfect continue. Otherwise, you will go back and up
change the hyper parameters. So these are all.
These are hyper parameters that we have here.
The number of voltage you choose is one hyperparameter. The
size of the filter is another private parameter the size
of the structure. The number of strides is not a hyper parameter. So there
are some experimentation involved.
Okay. Anyway, let me go and copy this finish this code
because we won't have 12 minutes left.
So conf 2D we then
use max pool again, and then one more convolutional layer.
We don't need the marks Max pool here that we will flatten it.
I've surely what flight does it from the slides in?
in
from module 1
and then we have
I'm not sure we'll be able to talk about.
the loss function which is
something called cross entropy
and for us to understand the soft Max.
activation function
we would need to talk cover some probability.
There's something called probability. There is something called the odds.
was the ratio of two probabilities because for
the activation function
In particular softmax function and the
loss function there were about to use me. We need to cover some.
probability Theory
the reason we have this flat layer.
Is to turn this Matrix into one
vector where the vector will represent the distribution.
whether it's sound bites whether it's pictures, whether
it's characters, whether it's
clusters
no matter what the
Modality of the data if you remember we talked about the modality we
said there are different ways to perceive data sound vision.
No matter what the modality of the data.
Ultimately, whatever the nature of
the data is it will turn into a distribution.
a distribution is this
everything must ultimately turn into one of these and the
shape of this.
The shape of the distribute the word distribution
really mean shape of the data.
So the shape of the data will determine what?
This thing is so for example if the distribution
is skewed, right?
It's skewed right when it when you have this downward this
tail that goes all to the right. So for
example, let's say if it's skewed right then it's a cat.
If it's centered, it's a car.
If it's bimodal, this is a bimodal distribution.
Like this. It's a truck.
So what the model we see is this it
cannot see colors it cannot see words. It
cannot hear sounds what I can see is these distributions and
this is just
numbers that are plotted
but let me just show you one more thing just to get my point across with this
flattened layer.
So you have your image?
comes in three color channels
At the end what we're going to do is gonna flood it. This will become a distribution so
you can see here in the right.
We can see the distribution of colors.
So all of these pictures that you see up here, they will all have
their own distinct fear distributions.
That's it.
This densely then.
This one down here in particular.
Is to give us the 10 possible classes to which the
particular picture belongs in order. So
we will have the top
10 classes. We only have 10 classes anyway, but it
will give you the top 10 classes in order of higher probability.
And that's it.